the challenge is they don't know what
how do you define what
is radicalizing because it's it's
subjective perspective
the disingen the disingenuousness of and
the the intent which is a hard thing to
prove yes
like obviously if someone's putting out
fake news misinformation sure and
disruptive
like but if someone says something like
my opinion on taxation is x
let me put it this way if you
purposefully
use things like botnets malware
um click fraud ad fraud and you use that
to boost your message
that is fraud and that defallus
advertising it's 100 fraud if you call
yourself a journalist or in the media
doing that i'm going to find you and i'm
going to take your money out of your
pockets
and that's what i've been working on the
past i'm going to avoid saying some
names
oh they've their servers have already
been scraped we hired 12 security
who's a renowned um systems
administrator wait am i am i
am i supposed to assume what you're
talking about oh you don't have to he's
been in like the washington post
and the new york times you discovered
the the way i was going to tell you that
yeah oh yeah he's discovered several
zero-day exploits and he's like 29 from
texas a maniac wait who who's this guy
what's
his name's dan erlick
so you wait you found stuff in
newspapers or what or
exploits breaking into them no we have
found a um
i mean we can talk about um cern of
excite is that his name cernovich
i don't know who he is i never knew who
he was until he started looking at his
website these people don't really
i don't get on my radar because it's
just i have no interest in what they're
talking about but
um you know we have a report here that
talks about
you know mega3x yeah what is it
amplification a hashtag movement is what
it could
simply be like hashtag mega3x but we
have you know there's pretty good
evidence that it was used to arrange
real-life flash mobs
and attract certainly attract american
sympathizers online who would agree to
spread memes
and conspiracy theorists and stuff like
that and the reason we know that is
because jeff giusea you're familiar with
jeff
he wrote a um kind of treaties on me
more memetic warfare
and people i think a lot of people
understand that memes
and mimetics are like genes and genetics
a meme is
it's a unit of cultural currency if you
will so i i know about moga 3x
it was it was literally cernovich
posting on twitter it was something like
for every trump supporter get three of
your friends you might go out and do
stuff i think that's how it started but
whatever it
turned into was a lot bigger than that
what was it
okay
i mean look there's and what is this
what is this from well this is from
mike's dms right so yeah these these
very clearly spell out a conversation
with uh what's his name
baked uh i don't know his real name
ginette something like that i really
don't know these people so these i have
no
horse in this game i've tweeted it out i
mean like hey i want to talk but um
you know this is like basically him and
baked alaska having a falling out
over just looks like uh right after
or right before the deplorable so i
think yeah um and you know
he actually you know this this thing
baked alaska makes it says you know
um i don't know if you can see that or
the camera yeah carefully
the memes he was posting it's the me
it's a meme though i mean like yeah but
yeah so that that
so that dude started getting more and
more
white nationalist yeah which resulted in
him getting banned from social media
right and then he got booted from a
bunch of events for
posting these things and like yeah yeah
no it seems as such but i
also know that around that time
various um soup packs um
and super pacs were formed that one of
them which was retroactively formed
and also this talk of this amplification
network and what we would assume is a
botnet
started to talk started to form and we
have very clear evidence that that was
happening let's
we i know we probably glossed over a lot
of like too much stuff already
sure but just explain what a botnet is
well botnet is an
and it's a very uh it can be a misnomer
um because it's shorthand for sort of
any amplification that's fraudulent or
happens and it doesn't even have to be
illegal uh so fraudulent would
mean anything from hey 20 or 30
of my traffic is boosted through paid
clicks or paid advertising
it could mean i have malware on my
machine that infects your machine
and creates a ghost browser that you
know can can
push three that thirty thousand
redirects in ten seconds across
the internet while your computer's
asleep basically it's a it's a network
of robots
it's a network to take over everyone's
computer and it's gotten so good that ai
based off of documents and this is
something that you can see on mic
servers right
is like placed into a bunch of um
document bins
and the ai will do everything from tweet
to do facebook to
uh who knows really that's beyond my
technical level but dan
we were putting together a massive
report on this that will be transparent
we've already given the ips over to a
lot of people we've even found some
so so what is it it's like what's the
bottom line
it's a amplification network that makes
stories that are that are that are
disingenuous and outright
incorrect stuff like the sethridge story
it propagates that in a way that
gets into size people's heads but
everyone knows that memes do that and
it's not a meme in the sense of a
visual thing it's an actual cultural
idea that becomes permanent
it also commits fraud that monetizes
this
disingenuous action and it undermines
u.s security interest
so you have a report saying that the
intention
is to no i am reporting and parallel
reconstructing
very various sources that i have that
are exclusive and we're corroborating it
and that's what we're doing i think part
two of our report
there's a lot of this centers around a
chinese national name guo
way but we're not going to get into that
unless you want to but it's it's that
stuff's bonkers but like
we would have to sit here for four hours
which i would so so
the bottom line what is it there's
american interests that have created
it's a national security issue and it's
not just american interest yeah and it's
a foreign relations issue
and it should be prosecuted to the full
extent of the law but what is it like
what's happening
you were undermining u.s security
interest by by one defunding
legitimate journalism like that's just
from a professional standpoint but we
can put that aside
two doing stuff like having spoof
certificates on your website that can
back door into what appear to be
government servers that's at least from
what i understand and what i'm
looking at and i'm not going to be
specific about who server that
is on but he knows who it is and that
you'd agree that it's undermining
national security interest if someone
could do that right do what do what
what false exactly if they could back
door into government servers
of course okay and three um
it's disingenuous you know stuff like
mcmaster's leaks and that kind of stuff
is is is
faulty and disingenuous well i guess
what i mean is you're saying that
you're undermining there are
international interests that have
created an ai that can
boost fake news like this information no
i would say there's a blend of
okay it's hypothetical but let's say
that i'm a country like people forget
that it's not just it's not russia or
china or this
ever heard of a red hat hacker yeah i'm
banned from china because i tried to
report on red hat hackers back in 2013.
so explain
for people who don't know so people know
what a black and uh white hat hack
well they don't they don't they know
what they know they know like the garth
brooks saw i know
i don't know who wrote it good guys
always wear white or whatever you know
like
a black hat and a white hat cowboy you
know that right
so like a red hat is it really is a
reference to communism because it's
uh it came out of a chinese sort of
china didn't have the internet at the
same time the u.s did and when they did
they got it it was actually run through
hong kong
servers the internet exchange there
right only recently has ch
mainland china gotten servers and those
servers
um you know there's there's people uh
before the great
chinese firewall which is hal china's
internet sensor right
um stuff like tiananmen square you can't
watch it right um
it's supposed to be removed all
references so the redhead hackers are
people that are security analysts quote
unquote
that get to basically have free access
to the internet in exchange for their
services
which would be anything you know that's
in line with the chinese
government's interest yeah and i
interviewed several of these folks
because it was right after snowden
had a great time talking to them because
we really spoke in the same way blank
i'm like you don't
you're not even loyal to the chinese
governor you're loyal to the internet
and
yes you get it you get it right it's
true but
if you're in china and you want full
access to the internet you're gonna have
to do that
right so the red hat hackers will always
act in the interest of the nation state
that they're from but at the end of the
day they're just hackers and hacker
culture comes from the united states
they're like pirates yeah like how
pirates used to be so exactly and in
exchange for those services they
basically had immunity right so if they
can commit cyber crime on the side
it's a great way to plausibly deny
influence from foreign actors like if i
give you a bunch of malware and say i'm
gonna put on your server's tim
right or whatever and that amplifies
your message
it it helps me because it's on your
servers
you're even if i'm maintaining the
databases that it connects to
and using those databases to sell it to
you know
all sorts of various actors both
legitimate and illegitimate
um it's a great way for me to walk away
from and say i didn't have anything to
do with that that was all tim
right right yeah that's it's how they
did it's how the pirates operated
in the uh colonial eras i guess it
wasn't just one time but
they would give privateers private
warships
letters of mark go do your thing help
us and then we'll disavow all knowledge
but you know you're free to loot and
pillage our enemies
so then you essentially have these
hacker groups that the government can go
oh no oh they're criminals oh heavens we
didn't sanction these hackers but
they're doing things that help
their nation state right yeah and the us
is more reluctant to do that because
it you know it's in some ways it's an
exploit against our freedom of speech
and
the boundaries of the law in the u.s for
a free nation
so are you saying that china was
interfering in the u.s elections
i'm saying that they've been long
interfering along with many other actors
that operate
both in sync with nation-state interest
as well as in their own interest
and that's a pretty easy thing to
understand and i think you also got a
look outside of the election
because it's not just the election this
has been stuff that's going on
beyond just decision making at the
highest ends of the government
so like what's what's going on well
let's get into the meat potatoes yes
okay well people are being compromised
at all levels of the government and also
in private sectors
and i think compromise how like what
does that mean
well whether you want to call them
assets uh spies
you know for china not just china but
yeah sure
we'll say that no no no no but for like
international
uh interest you know yeah because there
are other countries that have allowed
mutually aligned interests
and will work together or they'll just
work on their own right right and i'll
say china specifically has a very robust
uh ministry of state security that
spends billions of dollars
on compromising americans and they've
done a lot of that already
do you guys know about how they were
going after these university professors
and the
what was it is that related to it yep
really
there's a list there's a list of spies
and lists that have been
used against databases guo was a
person that was very interested in this
we'll say and people like michael waller
were very or at least
duped or wittingly unwittingly
deposition isn't clear because pages are
missing
they used databases that were
pre-existing so if i have a facebook
database and i have a healthcare
database
and i know the spy names are 25 spies
right and i use enough interrelated
databases just
to kind of compare these things i might
be able to out who they are based off
interrelated
characterizations and and and
psychographic data points right
but that's not definitive that's like
well it is digestive when you find out
that obama or somebody had 15 of them on
a
uh what didn't dianne feinstein have
somebody it butts up against security
issues
and you find that out very quickly you
know thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time